الاسرائيلي افاد مراسل الجزيره بان مئات
المحتجين على خطه الاصلاحات القضائيه
يعرقلون حركه الدخول الى مطار بن غريون
ومن هناك ينضم الينا من شرق تل ابيب مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام ليضعنا في سوره الان
امام مدخل المطار ولماذا عرقله الحركه
امام مداخل المطار
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل المتصاعده هذه الايام احتجاجا على
خطه الاصلاحات القضائيه التي تسعى حكومه
اقصى اليمين في اسرائيل الى تشريعها في
الكنيست الاسرائيلي والانقلاب على السلطه
القضائيه كما يقولوا المحتجون وكذلك هم
يقولون بان هذه الخطه تمس اسس الديمقراطيه
في اسرائيل ومبدا الفصل بين السلطات حوالي
3000 شرطي في انحاء اسرائيل يقومون
يحتشدون من اجل هذه
الاحتجاجات في اكثر من 130
اوقات قبل قليل اغلق هنا هذا المدخل
المدخل المؤدي الى مطار بن غوريون الدولي
شرقه تل ابيب بعشرات السيارات الان دخلت
الى داخل المطار وهي تعيط حركه الداخلينا
اليه بشكل كبير وذلك عشرات من المواقع في
داخل اسرائيل التي تشهد احتجاجات
واحتكاكات مع الشرطه الاسرائيليه هناك
ايضا اغلاق لميناء حيفا البحري بعشرات
الزوارق البحريه التي وصلت الى الميناء في
اطار هذه الاحجاجات الشعبيه الاحتجاج
الاهم هنا في مطار بن غوريون ياتي مع
استعداده رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
لمغادره اسرائيل في زياره رسميه الى
ايطاليا المحتجون يحاولون عرقله هذه
الرحله وعركله عرقله حركه الاقلاع لكن
يبدو ان بنيامين سيصل محاشيته الى المطار
بطائره عاموديه
سيتوجه الى
ايطاليا لكن الاهم في ذلك هو ان
الاجتماعات مع وزير الدفاع الامريكي الذي
يصل ايضا الى اسرائيل كلها حولت الى مطار
بن غوريون الدولي خشيه من ان تعيق
الاحتجاجات واغلاقات الطرق في اسرائيل هذه
الاجتماعات وتؤخر زياره بنيامين نتنياهو
الى ايطاليا لذلك كل الاجتماعات التي
سيعقدها وزير الدفاع الامريكي في اسرائيل
ستجري داخل المطار بحضور وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يقف جلنط وايضا رئيس هيئه
الاركان العامه في الجيش الاسرائيلي هرتز
في هذه الزياره على قدر كبير من الاهميه
بطبيعه الحال بالنسبه للمسؤولين
الاسرائيليين وهي تاتي مع سلسله من
الزيارات المتتاليه لمسؤولينا امريكيين في
اسرائيل ربما تحمل في طياتها ايضا مخاوف
من جانب الاداره الامريكيه من ان حكومه
اقصى اليمين ربما ستفاجئ الاداره
الامريكيه في عمل عسكري ضد المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه وهذه الزياره تريد ربما
ان تتاكد من خلالها الاداره الامريكيه بان
اسرائيل لا تنوي القيامه بضربه استباقيه
دون التنسيق مع الاداره الامريكيه في هذا
الخصوص لكن ايضا الاداره الامريكيه تاتي
وهي تحمل مطالب ايضا من من اسرائيل الاول
ان اسرائيل تريد من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ان تعمل على خفض التصعيد الامني في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله لان التصعيد
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله يعرقل
الحوار الاستراتيجي ويعرقل الحوار ما بين
واشنطن وتل ابيب فيما يتعلق بالملف النووي
الايراني ومن ناحيه اخرى الاداره
الامريكيه تطالب ايضا حكومه اقصى اليمين
للاصغاء الى هذه الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في
اسرائيل التي كنا نتحدث عنها حيث ان
الاداره الامريكيه لم تخفي مخاوفها من
خلال لقاءات مع مسؤولون اسرائيليين من ان
الانقلاب على الجهاز القض ائي في اسرائيل
من شانه ان يمس الاسس الديمقراطيه
لاسرائيل وهذا ما لا ترضاه الاداره
الامريكيه في هذا السياق وهي ترى بانه
ايضا سوف يعرقل الحوار الاستراتيجي
المتعلق بالملف النووي الايراني شكرا لك
كرم مراسله جزيره من مدخل مطار بن غوريون
شرق